right okay I'm gonna grab my water
bottle quick sorry uh so thanks everyone
for coming in this morning thanks to the
organizers for letting me give me a
chance to talk about this stuff yeah so
I guess let's just get started so this
is this is joint work with Mike and
Martin and what I'd like to do in this
talk is to just try to sort of bring
together some some of the classical
concepts of the decision theory and
statistics and some of the newer
concepts of privacy that we've been
hearing about for the past few days so
let me let me just sort of start with a
picture of the problem set up that we're
going through so we have some I mean at
first this is going to sort of seemed
like the same story we've been hearing
since Wednesday so we have some database
and it's got data x1 through xn and we
have some statistician or learner or
something like that and wants to find
things out and so you know he or she
gets in this case I'm going to be
working in sort of the local model where
data is private before the statistician
even sees it but roughly he or she gets
you know some sort of use of the data x1
through XM that are going to be passed
through some privatizing channel which
i'm going to call queue and sort of
nominally the goal is to infer sort of
global statistics about the database say
you know i want to compute the average
salary of everyone in this room but what
we're going to sort of be looking at is
something slightly different than then
this setup and that's that i'm going to
assume that there's some sort of
probability distribution p and its kind
of hiding behind the scenes and it's
what actually generates this data and
now there's some statistic or some
quantity some parameter sort of stata
which is a function of the distribution
P and this is what I'm actually
interested in in reconstructing and so I
might want to do this say to sort of
make sort of further predictions on the
data or you know do inferences sort of
about scientific things like you know
some basic facts about biology or
something like that then
really care what specifically happens in
the database I just care about what's
happening at sort of this population
level so these are the types of problems
that I'm going to be thinking about and
so that right the picture is that you
know that this sample x1 through xn is
not observed I only get to see the Z is
these private things and now the goal is
how do we infer this parameter theta so
that's going to be the setup we're
working in so sort of the standard thing
except we want to solve for this
population thing rather than anything
about the data itself okay so um let me
just now take a step back and sort of
i'm going to i'm going to get out of the
privacy mode completely and go back sort
of 30 years or something like that just
to the the classical minimax theory and
statistics so here's you know this is
the same picture we had except now
everyone is trusting because this is the
this is the 70s or the 80s and everyone
trusts everyone else you know like I did
when I was a baby and I was a baby good
so we've got you know our data x1 to xn
I the statistician see everything and
now I want to infer things about theta
this population parameter you know
because I'm going to try to make some
predictions in the future based on based
on this so let's talk about just sort of
how we how we how we how we sort of
discuss problems like this so the
central object of study in both this
this classical setting and for the sort
of privacy setting that we're going to
do in the later parts of the talk it's
going to be what's called the minimax
risk so I have my parameter of the
population distribution say the mean
because I just want to estimate the need
of my distribution and I'm going to have
some loss that measures my error the
error of some estimate theta hat for the
truth 8ax so i might say if i'm
estimating me and i might look at say
the euclidean distance squared between
the mean and whatever i predict or some
kind of more esoteric or robust losses
something like the huber loss you know
where i have kind of a quadratic penalty
around the origin but then things only
grow linearly outside it and there's i
mean we could sort of stick anything you
want in for this this loss row
and then there's going to be sort of
this family of distributions that I care
about studying because if there was only
one distribution in the world then
things would be easy I would know what
that distribution was I could just call
it a day but so we have some family of
distributions that were curious about
we're sort of trying to figure out which
which distribution in this family do I
get my data from so that might be all
distributions with some finite second
moment okay now that we've we've got
this how we're going to measure the
performance of our estimator is via the
expected loss or the risk so we have our
loss row evaluated on theta hat our
estimator which was constructed with the
data and we look at sort of a worst-case
over distributions p so what's the worst
possible risk for all distributions in
this family and what we want to do is
look at sort of the best possible
estimator so we're going to take in
infimum or minimize over all possible
estimators that take the data to my
parameter space sorry this should be an
ex not a Z and then this is sort of this
is this is the minimax risk so this is
the classical object okay and and sort
of the the main goal in in studies of
this thing is to understand as the
sample size n goes to infinity what's
the rate that the minimax risk goes to
zero or presumably it does go to zero
and we want to understand exactly what
its behavior is now we can argue that
sort of an estimated we've come up with
his optimal or things like that row
could be the indicator and then the
expectation of the indicators are
probably there so those are used to
classification problems that nest within
this framework my obvious but just
reported yeah rates of the classifier
hmm yeah so we want to we want to sort
of explicitly kind of calculate exactly
what this function is or at least sort
of upper and lower bounds on it that are
tight to constant factors okay and all
you you look perturbed okay yeah so this
is I mean so so this is this is what
we're going to be sort of studying
worst-case distribution best possible
estimator okay and so so when we when we
prove these these minimax bounds well in
this talk I'm going to just kind of give
ad-hoc upper bounds on my on the minimax
risk i'm just going to give you an
estimator and say hey look here is here
is its behavior the lower bounds are
going to be information theoretic and
this these techniques are sort of came
out of basically russia and france sort
of in the late 70s early 80s starting
with has Minsky and then beers and
bergamot and has Minsky and then sort of
continuing on with other authors sort of
to the present day and just sort of as
an aside we could give information
theoretic upper bounds on these
quantities but I'm going to be I'm going
to sort of avoid this for the for the
talk so so the the high-level outline of
how we how we discuss or how we prove
these minimax bounces we sort of do this
three-step process in the first step
we're going to take our estimation
problem and we're going to transform it
into a testing problem so we take
whatever estimation problem we had and
we show how it becomes the same as sort
of a test then we're going to there's
sort of a canonical testing problem
floating behind the scenes that we're
going to have sort of reduce things too
I mean this these really are just
reductions which should be familiar to
many of us and then we can actually
there's a bunch of many known sort of
information theoretic bounds on error
probabilities then we can give lower
bounds using those and so let's go
through these steps these three steps in
somewhat more detail I'm going to spend
a little bit of time writing on the
board so hopefully we won't get do this
too quickly so this first step is the
reduction from estimations are testing
so the way we do this reduction is we
start with our parameter space and our
parameter space is this big oval and so
what I'm going to what our reduction
starts with is I'm going to construct
what's called the two Delta packing of
my parameter space so this means I take
sort of theta 1 theta 2 up to some k so
I take a bunch of different parameters
I'm going to plunk them down across my
entire parameter space but what I want
to guarantee is that they're all well
separated okay so each of them has sort
of some Delta ball around itself and no
other parameter is within no other
parameters sort of neighborhood
intersects with with the other ones now
if I if you give me an estimated this
data hat it's the point is that it's
going to fall in sort of at most one of
these balls right I can't be in two
balls at the same time because they're
all this joint right so we drop our
estimator down here and then since at
most one index in this whole set is
close to theta hat if we can estimate
well then we can test which index this
is okay so if you came to me and said
here's an estimator and it gets it it
gets within Delta of the true parameter
then I say well while the two parameters
are theta1 theta2 theta3 etc if you say
I'm within Delta of one of those and I
can tell you exactly which one you are
close to okay so now this I mean this
picture is the we've taken sort of this
continuous estimation problem to a
problem of just tell me which of these
balls is the true parameter okay so
we've taken this sort of continuous
space thing and made it into just let's
identify a parameter
okay so once we have this now we have
sort of this canonical what I'm going to
call the canonical testing problem and
how this canonical testing problem works
is nature chooses some random index V
from our set so there were there K of
these guys in the packing k will always
be the sizes of our of our packings and
nature is going to choose whoopsie wrong
way one of these uniformly at random and
then conditional on this choice I'm
going to sample the data iid from
whatever distribution whatever parameter
is plunked down at that guy and then I
get this lower bound on the minimax
error based on this so let's let's
actually do the sort of math so we go
through this not quite as awfully
quickly as we do so if we think about
the maximum error for our estimator we
have sort of the biggest to pnp the
biggest risk in our family of my loss
row of theta hat and data of p but now
so certainly the maximum is bigger than
the average right and so I can do this
step and I have this is greater than or
equal to my average rest sorry average
risk some from the equals 1 decay of the
expectation under sort of nature's
choice v of my risk or of my loss rather
and what for whatever it is for that
parameter theta V okay and now what I'm
going to say is ok everything is Delta
separated we sort of said that so i can
define i can define row of Delta this is
going to be sort of the minimal risk I
have four things that are far separated
so this is going to be the min over all
sort of theta in theta and the min over
the in my set it indices sorry
v.v in k of the distance such that the
distance between theta V is bigger than
Delta okay so I'm going to fight this is
sort of the this this is just if I
predict sort of this point or this fall
instead of this ball and this one is the
truth how much loss do I have that's all
that that's what that's all this
quantity is it's just sort of you know a
lower bound on how much loss i have for
getting myself in the wrong ball okay
and then once I've got that once I have
this quantity than this now so if I make
a mistake meaning my my estimator is far
away then clearly I have to suffer loss
at least sort of this this quantity this
minimal separation so this is now lower
bounded by one on k some v equals 1 to k
of the expectation under V of my sort of
minimal loss times the indicator that I
made a mistake and I make a mistake if
my distance I guess row of theta hat and
theta v is greater than or equal to stop
yeah i'm using notation a little bit so
let's yeah let's yeah let's we can do it
this way it doesn't it's not hugely
matter but yes it should just be
parameter distance so we have this and
now this now is just I can pull this out
this is just the probability of error so
this is greater than or equal to the
probability that that sort of row of or
sorry
theta hat minus theta v is greater than
Delta where V is chosen uniformly at
random for my set times this separation
and that is what we end up at here so
what this is sort of the final canonical
testing problems of this whoopsie this
is certainly bigger than that the
smallest error I could ever have in some
tests where I'm just trying to find the
index so this is greater than or equal
to men over all possible tests that find
this index of the probability that I
make a mistake okay
so that's a lower bound on my mini max
risk so now so this is our canonical
testing problem is and now the whole the
whole rest of the goal is just the whole
rest of the scheme now is just to try to
find lower bounds on this probability
there okay any questions make e yes yeah
so the question is how do we choose sort
of this this radius Delta in our packing
and there's lots of ways to do that and
I'm going to go through an example in a
little bit where we actually sort of
explicitly gave lower bounds on this and
we'll see sort of what the scaling of
Delta that we're going to choose is okay
yes can all so just so I understand so
you think there's some distance in the
parameter space they take so that it
would be hard to test yes in some new
tables and 10 tonight with respect to
that yep and it's wrong Delta relates
that distance to the loss that you care
about mmhmm yeah exactly could you
rephrase this a singer a little mountain
air max risk by the base risk on a
finitely supported prior yes that's
exactly what we're doing we're sort of
taking we're taking a minimax risk and
then we're giving it a lower bound by a
base risk where the bays risk is uniform
on the different spheres if that mixing
is clear yes it's exactly what you could
do okay and then we have then then sort
of the step the third step is to give
kind of classical balance on these error
probabilities and because all we care
about now is this about lower bounding
this probability of error and there's
two well there's many there are many
many methods for doing this but the two
that we're going to talk about in this
talk is the first is what's known as la
coms method and this says what this says
is that by if I only have two points so
so theta zero and theta 1 then the
probability I make a mistake sort of the
average probability I make a mistake is
bigger than 1 minus the total variation
distance between the distributions that
I'm getting information from and this is
just a calculation to
to show this type of lower bound and
then the if we have sort of more than
two sort of parameters that we're
carrying about distinguishing then we
can use what's known as fan owes
inequality and this is an
information-theoretic bound and it says
roughly that my probability of error is
bounded by lower bounded by 1 minus this
mutual information quantity plus this
additional term divided by log case so
roughly what this says is that you know
if I have K different centers it takes
log K bits to describe them and you know
I get some number of bits from my
statistical procedure and basically my
error is related to the ratio of the
bits i receive versus the number of bits
that are there in the actual problem and
so the sort of the summary then the
summary picture is that you know nature
chooses some random index V in my set
and then it generates X and I the
estimator you know I want to figure out
sort of theta V whatever theta is
associated with this random parameter
and I'm constructing some theta hat
which allows me to construct a test to
figure out which V this is and then the
whole game is figuring out how much
information is there actually in this
channel here ok come on some tight mean
the way you described it it would seem
it should be exponential in that because
10 bits missing really I should've won
you want to do to the 10 probability of
getting it right ah this this is tight
yes it is it is tight and so the way
that we make it tight is related to
Mickey's question earlier which is that
we're going to choose these deltas to be
sort of shrinking at a very particular
rate that's going to make this sort of
rough this whole quantity will always be
roughly a half give or take that is it's
tight but I guess what i was asking is
if the numerator is much smaller than
the denominator can this inequality be
improved
I don't know I mean engine in general
this is type and it son improvable but
there may be I mean if you want to sort
of talk about exponential inequalities
there are different ways to do this in
information theory where we can get sort
of the right exponents and things and I
don't believe this gives you the right
exponents it just gives you sort of
scalings okay so let's um so let me uh
right so basically the key when we're
proving these these lower bounds is to
control these information theoretic
divergences either the variation
distance between the distributions I
care about or the mutual information in
my problem okay so let me do a let's do
a quick example here of how we of how we
do this and I'm going to do it just for
sort of a very simple problem and and
hopefully that'll make clear sort of
where we're what what I'm doing in the
rest of the talk so let's let's consider
the following problem this is going to
be sort of the canonical statistical
problem and there are many many ways to
get lower bounds on this that are going
to be at least sort of constant factors
sharper than what I do but this is
hopefully the one of the simpler things
that I can i can describe here so let's
just consider the family of
distributions i'm just going to do
normal sorry we're going to do normal
location estimation
and so the family of distributions i
care about is going to be it's going to
be basically distributions normal with
mean some means theta and variance Sigma
squared times the identity okay excuse
me so this is going to be my family of
distributions and now I want to
understand how hard is it to estimate
this data and so the somehow the the
upper bound is is simple right so and
the upper the upper bound we're going to
get is just you know the use the sample
mean if I get n samples and that's going
to have e of theta hat minus theta
squared is less than or equal to just
Sigma squared times the dimension
divided by n ok so this is into it
presumably this is the right rate and
we'll see that it is and now the
question is how do we show our our lower
bound so so the first step in showing
lower bound is constructing our well
separated packing excuse me and and and
the way we're going to construct the
packing is by by using sort of the
varsha mob gilbert coding sort of
construction of codes if you want to
call it a construction of codes or just
a varsha mob gilbert packing of the
hypercube so we're going to sort of take
the hyper cube minus 11 to the D and
there's a theorem that says I can take a
large number of elements from this that
are all very well separated sort of on
the order of D units apart and and so
the varsha mob Gilbert bound says
I can take there's a a packing which
I'll call sort of you which will be a
subset of this hypercube such that the
cardinality of you is greater than X of
Dion aight i may get these constants
wrong but that's they're not going to be
important and if u and u prime are in
this packing you but they're not equal
then their distance say in l1 norm it's
going to be greater than or equal to D
on to so the sum the sum of the
coordinates but a different is going to
be at least sort of on the order of the
the dimension okay so I've got now this
is this is going to be sort of the base
of my packing and now what I'm going to
do actually and and we can see that
there's so now there's sort of this
exponential of guy exponential number of
guys in this packing what I'm going to
do is I'm going to sort of scale them
all by Delta so this is yes what's that
he which which usually depends on the
radius of the package it would but I'm
just fixing one right now I'm just I'm
only packing the hypercube yeah so
there's no everything is sort of on the
same order everything this depends on
one and so the way I'm going to
construct these my parameters now is I'm
going to say so now that construct my
parameters I'm going to just I'm going
to choose these i'm going to choose sort
of the subfamily here i'm going to index
it by the elements of this packing and
i'm going to just say theta associated
with you is going to be delta x you
whoops that my computer just turning off
okay and once I've got this now what we
can what we can see immediately is that
the sort of separation of these
different guys is going to be roughly of
the order delta squared times u squared
in l2 squared norm sort of theta u minus
theta u Prime and l2 squared will be
bigger than or equal to delta squared
times the dimension over is that I think
that's correct yes it's delta squared
times the dimension because every time
they're different they're two units
apart i'm squaring it i get 4 and that's
going to cancel out these anyway it's
going to be on this order and now the
question is okay so now I've got so then
i have this minimax lower bound
according to the theory that says
minimax bound for this family in l2
squared error is going to be greater
than or equal to delta squared times d
times the mutual in five and i'm going
to use the fan i'm going to use the fano
inequality lower bound which is right
there so 1 minus the mutual information
between what i actually see and a random
index rooms is set / the log of this
packing size which is going to be at
least scaling with the dimensions so d
divided by 8 ok and now basically now so
this now the question is okay what's an
upper bound on the mutual information
and so the technique I'm going to use
now is called has many names some people
call it generalized spanos inequality
some people call it idiot fan was
inequality it's sort of both but it's
just a simple naive bound on this mutual
information and what we what we do is we
say that so now
so we're going to bound this information
and this is less than or equal to since
it's just these are sort of iid samples
according to be we can it's less than or
equal to the sum of the individual
informations and now what we want to do
is give an upper bound on this quantity
and this is going to head over here so
hopefully everyone can still see we know
that the mutual information here this is
equal to the KL well it's equal to 1 on
sort of the number of elements in my
packing times the average KL divergence
between sort of TB and P bar where P bar
is equal to the average over everything
in my packing so this is just the
definition of mutual information it's
the average scale the virgins between if
I averaged first and the individual
distributions conditional 1b and then KL
divergence is convex so this is less
than or equal to sort of the all pairs
average of these distributions which is
just the KL divergence between normal
theta B Sigma squared identity and
normal theta V prime Sigma squared
identity but we know what the KL
divergence between normal distributions
is is just the l2 distance squared and
what's the l2 distance between these
Thetas will I constructed them there and
it's going to be bounded by something
like four times Delta squared so this is
now less than or equal to 4 delta
squared divided by Sigma squared because
Sigma is my co variance for variance
x d I'm sorry because we're in D
dimensions so now we can see all right
if I just plug this in if I just plug
this in over there what I'm going to get
is a lower bound on the minimax risk
which will be minimax risk greater than
or equal to Delta square d x 1 minus n
well we'll have 32 n delta squared D
Sigma squared divided by D okay I'm just
plugging in numbers and doing the math
because I had four and then eight on the
bottom over there and now we can see
immediately well maybe not immediately
but the Delta I'm going to choose to
make this large I just want to make this
quantity a half or something like that I
just need to make my probability of
error some constant and I'm going to
suffer a lot of loss most of the time so
if I choose delta squared equals well
basically just Sigma squared divided by
n oh I'm sorry this is a / say 64 m then
this quantity is going to be a half and
I'm going to get I'm going to get that
this is greater than or equal to Sigma
squared times the dimension / 128 and
okay so this is this is the one example
of how we prove minimax lower bounds in
this in this framework so we step one we
do our packing which is to reduce from
estimation is testing step two we have
this canonical testing problem which in
this case is choose a random vector from
a hypercube and then draw normal samples
with that mean and then step three is to
give an error probability bound which we
do by controlling the mutual information
or something like it or a total
variation distance so that we did all
those three steps here and yeah so
that's the game okay and so can all this
answers your question if you know how do
we and Mickey we choose Delta sort of so
that this roughly that our probability
of error is sort of constant even as
grows so death is going to be shrinking
at some rate to make this mutual
information scaling okay any questions
on that cool
alright so for the rest of the talk then
now we're going to jump back into the
privacy land and we're going to talk
about what effects privacy has and
specifically what we're going to see is
that privacy has very interesting
effects on these two distances on the
total variation distance and on the
mutual information here so jumping back
to our privacy picture we have we have
these you know this is our picture here
here's me I want to figure out things
about this population parameter and I
don't get to see the actual data so now
this is just a minor tweak on this on
this previous game that we've set up so
the model of privacy that I'm going to
be using for the rest of the excuse me
rest of the talk it's called local
privacy and local privacy means that
basically the providers of the data
don't even trust the collector which you
shouldn't trust me at all because I will
steal your data and sell it to people
and so the picture here is that you know
our data comes in x1 through xn there's
this barrier it goes into the method or
statistician and out pop some estimator
and the notation which I already set up
a bit is that we have this channel X
goes into this channel which I'll denote
by Q and out pops Z and that goes into
the method okay and the sort of and and
so these individuals all have personal
data according to the distribution that
we care about and our estimator is now
just a function of the disease okay so
we're going to use the definition that
we're going to we're going to use
differential privacy is our definition
of privacy which we should we're
probably all familiar with by now and so
we're going to just say this channel is
alpha differentially private if you know
it has this likelihood ratio about and
so we've all sort of seen this and you
know the picture is if I i plot kind of
the log-likelihood then everything you
know every distribution no matter what X
or X prime you start from everything is
within some window of with alpha so
everything looks sort of the same and
the I mean you know we sort of I mean
based on promote stock yesterday and
many other lots of other work we sort of
know we have something to wish
what these definitions mean and so so so
roughly you know given some vector Z
from this private channel we don't know
what X actually gives you all right so
now that now we're going to go back to
this minimax risk that I started with at
the beginning of the talk except we're
going to do a private version of it and
so you know we have the usual setup
parameter loss family of distributions
and now we're going to look at the
expected loss again except it's now now
we our estimator is a function of Z 1
through ZN rather than the actual data
and as before we look at a worst case
over distributions p and the best case
overall estimators so this is this is
still purely the classical setup but we
have this week now that we're going to
look at private things and so we're also
going to look at sort of a best-case
overall private channels q where q takes
X to Z so basic so roughly that this
estimator theta hat and this sort of
privacy preserving guy are going to work
together to make our estimators as good
as possible under the constraint that
these things are kept private and this
is the private minimax risk so this is
this is what what I would like to talk
about for the rest of my my little spiel
any questions about this okay cool so so
you know now what one now what our goal
is to understand precisely how does this
change this quantity change with my
privacy parameter alpha and the sample
size and so that's that's the whole game
and yes yes that would be hopeful yes
for sure yes definitely okay so so far I
mean I haven't used anything exactly so
if I have just given a definition yes I
can definitely do that because the local
model will be sort of essential for for
the results I'm going to prove and well
I'm going to get sharper lower bounds
that definitely don't hold in a global
model ok but so certainly there are many
related results to sort of studying
things like this there's been a lot of
work on sort of
non population lower bounds meaning how
much if I want to compute a statistic of
my actual database how much error do I
have to suffer so more it's an all did
some work on this and then more recently
saw show and and these guys and I mean
many many others have done work on this
in this sort of more population type
case that we're considering there's been
a little bit less work but certainly
there has been work sort of soco Malika
and Daniel did some work on sort of what
I'll call to point hypotheses which is
roughly which is sort of related to the
lecom thing I showed earlier and then
some work by vinyl and co-authors in
2008 showed some lower bounds that
roughly relate to sort of how well can
we estimate the bias of sort of
one-dimensional kind of coins or
something like that and they give a
lower bound of one on and alpha squared
in the error okay I I'm this is roughly
what their results seem to imply so
these things are there and then sort of
in that in the more global model there's
been work on pack learning my many
people so if if I forget to reference
somebody forgive me I'm just putting
things on slides but so the the most
recent stuff while there there's a sec
reporting 2013 or some earlier work on
sort of pact learning lower bounds and
things like this okay I just a squared
loss swear yeah
oh I'm sorry no the parentheses are in
the wrong place that squared should only
be in the Alpha thank you on I'm sorry
yes that's a typo good catch yeah right
this this should go inside that
parentheses okay so but yeah so there's
been there's there certainly even work
on this and but we're going to just try
to give a sort of this more information
theoretic for you on this kind of your
buggy basically just plug and play you
try and kind of turn your crank and get
lower bounce ok so in the in our paper
papers on this there's we have a bunch
of examples mean estimation regression
convex risk minimization or online
learning things like this multinomial
estimation and density estimation sort
of nonparametric problems I'm going to
go through somewhat more carefully at
the mean estimation problem and the
multinomial probability estimation
problem in this talk okay so the first
example is mean estimation so let's just
say I have a one dimensional quantity
I'm curious about so I have some
distributions I'm going to look at them
with sort of K all distributions with k
moments where K is going to be bigger
than 2 i'm gonna give a say that they're
bounded by one so what I care about is
the mean and this is my family of
distributions okay so the picture I mean
is that so sort of the classical picture
is you know we have samples on the line
and we would usually just use the sample
need clearly this is not private and in
the local model what we're going to do
oh I'm sorry and this this when we just
use the sample mean we have sort of an
error excuse me an l2 square root of one
on em and but in the insert of this this
local privacy model that I have we kind
of need to add some type of noise to
these parameters sorry to the sample and
then we're going to say r es to make the
sample mean based on that and clear it's
clear that we're going to have whoopsie
a lot more noise in this estimator I
should point out that our assumptions on
the channel don't say you have to add
noise in any way they're sort of we're
totally oblivious to the channel you
could use any privacy preserving
distribution you want our lower bounds
will hold
and the the proposition that we get is
that this non-private minimax rate goes
from one on n 21 on n alpha squared to
this power which relates to the number
of moments we have okay so one on n
roughly to the K minus 1 over K so we go
from sort of this parametric one on n
rate to something that's not quite so
hot and this is definitely specific to
the local model okay and sort of as two
exam as two examples we can just do a
calculation if I only have two moments
then I go from a one on n rate to a one
on route and rate so I sort of lost
roughly you know some very large
proportion of my samples in this local
model as long as if I don't have any
kind of compactness when I have
compactness meeting my random variables
are bounded say minus 11 then this is
just one on n alpha squared because I
can make k equals infinity okay but if
there's one thing I want you to I want
you to sort of remember this this sort
of scheme this sort of scaling and goes
to n alpha squared okay so it's a second
example multinomial estimation this is
sort of this classical problem i'm going
around i want to estimate you know i'm
taking surveys i want to estimate the
proportion of people with some type of
condition so i get observations x in 12
d and i want to compute the probability
that x is equal to j for j from 1 to d
you know suppose I'm want you know the
average salary of I don't know everyone
in San Francisco so I go around door to
door and asking people to fill out these
surveys you know you can check the box
IE that makes your 10,000 10,000 to
20,000 etc then the standard estimator
which is just to count up the proportion
of people who answer in each bucket my
error is at least in l2 we can do this
with other metrics whatever metric you
feel it like l1 we can do the same types
of calculations my error rate is going
to be basically one on n my I can just
you know you just do a calculation and
it's going to become one over N and that
proposition that we have which is going
to be
sequence of our more general results is
that the non private minimax rate goes
from one on em to d MV is the dimension
/ n officer ok so we went from one on n
to Dion and alpha squared and if there's
anything to take away from the slide I
want you to sort of think of my sample
size reducing from n so original i had n
samples and now i have n alpha squared
divided by the dimension and this is
this is going to be true sort of in
greater generality than just this but
this is this is the scaling we see ok
and the you know the nice thing is about
these things is we can actually optima
sorry we can identify optimal mechanisms
in this case the optimal mechanism is
just randomize response you know i hears
me filling out this survey of how much
money I make I don't need to keep this
private I'm a graduate student you know
all know exactly my salary but if I go
through this list every box I'm going to
flip a biased coin if it lands heads I'm
going to lie or sorry if it lands heads
I'll tell the truth of it lands tails
i'm going to lie in that box and so this
is Miri filling out this survey with
lying so you know the data you might get
is that I make 10,000 20,000 20,000
40,000 and more than three hundred
twenty thousand dollars per year and it
turns out that this is optimal so it's
going to attain sort of the lower bound
and the upper bound will match and be
exactly at the right scale okay so those
are two examples done let's sort of take
a step into this more general theory and
roughly the two sort of quote-unquote
theorems I put these in quotes because
these are not formal in any way or
rigorous but essentially the effective
sample size for almost any problem is
made worse by at least end n alpha
squared so you can't hope for better
scaling than that and when I say
essentially any I mean any sort of
statistical problem whose minimax rate
we know by information theoretic
calculations by something like this or
or met there are many others to which
our techniques will apply and for D
dimensional problems the sample size or
the effective sample size is going to
get scale as n goes to n alpha squared
divided by D
so you take sort of these sort of 15 or
16 characters are really all that you
really need to take home from this but
let's let's now talk about how we
actually show them and this is where
we're going to get where it's going to
be essential that we're sort of in this
local model of privacy okay so I've said
you know we sort of went through this
reduction from estimation to testing to
show minimax lower bounds so let's do
this in this private case so we have the
two parameters and the distribution
associated with them the problem is
going to be very challenging when my
distributions are not very far apart you
know if I can if nature looks sort of
the same no matter what its true state
is and it's going to be very hard for me
to distinguish them so there's the here
are two pictures this is an easy world
this is very hard because I can't tell
which distribution sort of nature has
okay so if I think about sort of the
actual mechanism by which I'm getting
information in this case i can think of
my samples see I these are the private
guys being drawn from this marginal
distribution so PD is the true
probability distribution but it's
getting pushed through this channel q
and what we have this is sort of the
first main theorem is what I'll call a
strong data processing inequality and
what this says is if I had two
distributions p1 and p2 when they get
passed through a channel to become m1
and m2 their KL divergences get shrunk
by this factor of roughly alpha squared
ok so that somehow the picture here is
that p1 and p2 may be far apart in the
beginning but if once they get passed
through this channel q they fall right
on top of each other ok and it's it's
it's very important that we get sort of
this p1 p2 distance here rather than
just something like alpha squared or
anything like that because this is what
will allow us to actually show the
scalings in these population cases so
well as stated this is it doesn't matter
because I just only have one sample but
yes it is local so if there were sort of
n guys if these were sort of
distributions over n thing
then I get an N here and it would be
essential that it's local yes this will
not hold in the global model at all yes
for it that was my question is will will
for the global model but on the Joint
Distribution so you don't get that but
the same in the quality is true ah yeah
except well you'll have an n alpha up
top right because the ratio is between
the distributions or you know if I'm
allowed to change so they're gonna
change everyone yeah so that's the issue
is that this this will this will this
technique I mean at least as stated is
going to not go through for the
non-local models and that's I think a
very interesting open question is trying
to make these information theoretic
arguments go through in the non-local
case we have one or two ideas in that
direction but they're very it's very
open since we know we can do better in
the global yeah ya know and so you have
different inequalities and the question
is can you make them make them sharpen
and we don't know the answers to that
yet I have very very sketchy preliminary
things that are there they work for
one-dimensional problems but somehow we
think that more than one dimension may
be reasonable for things we care about
Adam what's up soon one questions can
you say can you get this type of
inequality for alpha combat Delta
differential privacy yeah that's a good
question dan KL divergence would be
would be tricky there right so for KL
divergence um per KL divergence we
cannot get this inequality at least I
mean we may be able to get something
similar but there's some technical
issues that I don't know how to quite
deal with so that's a good question
there are we can sort of do it with if I
all i care about it sort of total
variation distances but with KL we can't
quite get it and KL seems to be
important for dealing with larger than
one sample but that's a very good
question so there's a lot of there's a
lot of things that we could that would
be worth or that I would like to
understand more and you know maybe you
guys would too but yeah very good
question and so so the picture I mean if
we if we go back to sort of Allah coms
method this is just the two point
hypotheses I didn't go through exactly
an example here
but you know I have distributions p1 and
p2 and they're going to be sort of two
Delta separated as we had in our packing
earlier so the non private version is
that and this is just by doing a
calculation with the reduction from
estimation of testing I have error
basically scaling as Delta squared which
is the separation if all i care about is
my squared error times the probability
of error in distinguishing these two and
that's going to be sort of n times their
KL divergence okay and then the private
version is that you know once I go
through this channel these things get
smashed on top of each other and these
would become m1 and m2 and this becomes
instead of n times the KL divergence
it's an alpha squared times the total
variation distance so we really do see I
mean this is n becomes n times alpha
squared and this is the [ __ ] this is
sort of this fundamental thing that we
have appearing in our in our
inequalities ok so that's that's that
and this is it's essential to get this
sort of correct scaling that everything
be in the local model so yes this is
this is very specific to the local model
ok so but we can also do this in the
sort of more high dimensional case so
not just to point hypotheses we can do
it with more so this is going to be the
fano inequality approach which is what
I've sort of sketched up on the board
behind me and so now you know nature
that we're sort of in this canonical
testing problem where now nature is
going to sample something uniformly from
one decay and then we have this Markov
chain V is the true state of nature
gives x and then x is privatised to z
and we saw earlier that you know mutual
information is fundamental here and so
now instead of computing the mutual
information between x1 through xn and
nature it's z1 through ZN and whatever
is happening in nature so the question
is how much small how do I compare this
to this quantity and so what we have is
this basically a sort of another kind of
data processing inequality kind of a
quantitative one and roughly what the
the consequence is going to be is that
in a d-dimensional problem whatever was
the probability of error in the non
private version is going to be scaled by
alpha squared where that's our privacy
parameter / the dimension so roughly
this is going to be the scaling that
we're going to see and so this is you
know whatever was the sample size is now
made worse by a factor of alpha squared
over deep and the specific theorem is is
this is that for any a non-interactive
channel meaning you know you provide
data and then it just goes through the
channel and the channel depends on
nobody else we have this kind of
behavior so the mutual information
scales as n times alpha squared times
this quantity which at first glance
looks kind of strange but if you do sort
of if you if you sort of squint your
eyes at it this starts to look a lot
like total variation distance excuse me
total variation distance would only have
two different distributions here in this
case we have a whole family of
distributions and their distance to the
average T bar and it turns out that
since this supremum is on the outside
this can be very very small or much much
smaller than sort of any reasonable
total variation distance with individual
guides and so if you and this makes
calculations but roughly what happens is
that if we do a calculation this sort of
total variation distance this kind of
dimension dependent total variation
looks roughly like the original mutual
information in the problem / whatever
the dimension was okay and so this this
is again the fact that this inequality
holds is certainly only true in the
local model in the global model we know
this is false okay and so roughly we
went from whatever was originally in the
problem to this scaled version which is
what's giving us our sample size hits
Adam what's up is there an operational
interpret
the thing with the thing in blue the
thing in blue you mean like it is it
associated with some kind of testing
eric liability or something like that
it's you can think of as a testing error
right yeah and I don't know I haven't
seen this anywhere it sort of just
popped out of our theorems and I mean it
looks like to liberation so maybe there
is some connection between like a multi
uh sort of a multi multi way hypothesis
test in la coms sort of setting I don't
know I just I have no idea yeah yeah but
it's a great question okay so now this
is you know so so what we what we see
really is that we have n goes to n alpha
squared over D so this is our thing okay
so let me just summarize and actually
sorry let me let me make one comment
what's interesting actually is if you
look at the proof of these these sort of
bounds they actually we can actually
almost explicitly construct what channel
gives you the most information and
there's very specific channels that give
you the most information it turns out
that those we can then use in our upper
bounds sort of in deriving mechanisms to
sort of say this is going to be the
optimal mechanism and so and the optimal
mechanisms often fall out of these lower
bound proofs which is kind of
interesting you can you know you prove a
lower bound but it's sort of almost an
algorithmic lower bound because it just
it kind of hands you you know here is
what you should be doing to actually
solve this problem optimally so I'm not
just a pessimist but anyway okay so let
me let me summarize so very high level
what I would have tried to do is make
some connections between sort of these
the sort of decision theoretic minimax
theory and in this case local
differential privacy we had sort of two
main theorems which were what i showed
in the last 10 minutes which bounded
distances between probability
distributions as a function of the
amount of privacy that we provide and we
saw sort of this pairwise contraction
and then this kind of mutual information
contraction and they worked in the two
different lower bounding styles mutual
information for what i wrote on the
board via
the fano method okay and and these were
our sort of two big fake theorems and
you know it so in our papers we have
sort of rates for different problems
rate regression convex optimization
things like this and turns out it's very
interesting there are some of these
dimension dependent effects so high
dimensional problems are effectively
impossible in the local model you're not
going to be able to solve some sports
high dimensional problem okay and and we
can identify optimal mechanisms as well
okay so so I hope you know I think
roughly we've sort of shown some kind of
trade-offs between privacy and
statistical utility there's clearly lots
of open problems here can we do this for
other models of privacy non-local
notions approximate differential privacy
there are sort of questions that you
know everything here was sort of I knew
what my statistical objective was at the
end of the day so now there's questions
of you know what exactly can we do to
privatize databases and still make them
useful in this framework that we set up
we know that's going to be much harder
and the results will be worse and there
have been you guys have done lots of
work on that yeah so there's a
post-print or preprint depending on what
you think is for your post online on the
archive so I'm happy to take some
questions if you have any more thanks
for your attention
yeah we have a couple minutes of
questions please so the result of
effective sample size I wonder and to
say generalizing to hydration is hard
but if I do have hydration theta but i'm
asking for lips and we should go I want
to be with nicotine and then sit up
there too and is there any idea yeah and
so I mean we know sort of L infinity
error you can get much better feeling on
that I mention even in the non private
case you're still going to hit get hit
with dimension dependent effects in this
local model yeah you're mean when I say
that n goes to n alpha squared over D
that's sort of true for many many many
problems so even if all you care about
is sort of some low dimensional quantity
if you don't know what it is apriori
it's going to be hard to figure out
information about it exactly the same
way I mean you had n and now becomes n
alpha squared over D and that's not a
guess it's it's true ah yeah yeah I
guess so the randomized response
mechanism what's interesting is that you
the output out you have flexibility in
your procedure to choose the output out
of it yes so now you're moving from
state list of salaries to reserve one
salary level two lists of salaries yes
beautiful open the output alphabet size
sort of Christian can you say anything
about what citizen alphabet size is for
certain we have like a lot of
flexibility there
what you wrote what the person gets to
report to the status ocean yeah I don't
that's a that's a good question and I'm
not sure I have any any good answers it
sort of feels like you're you're it sort
of feels like you should be able to do
all of this with a very small alphabet
because you're losing so much mutual
information in your problems but we
haven't I mean there's some interesting
connections between sort of the rates of
convergence we get here and what one
gets in like bandit online optimization
stuff so you sort of feel like you
should be able to just kind of consent
one dimensional quantities along but
that's just some very vague feeling I
have I can't make anything resistant yes
my upper bounds are I've another
mechanism which is the same rate yeah
exactly and and I don't know you know I
I don't know exactly what the right
things are I mean so so our data
processing inequalities are the first
one at least is sharp including the
constants as alpha goes to zero so it's
I mean it's it's really we can nail it
but I you know I don't know anyway ah do
any of these techniques handle and the
interesting piece for it yeah so that's
like that's a great question um so I
haven't been very careful here but yes
we can these techniques do extend to the
following picture so i can have so i
have x one and it generates z1 then I
have x2 and it can generate z2 but z2
can also depend on Z 1 and I can have x3
you know goes to Z 3 and that may depend
on Z 1 Z 2 so i can have sort of this
chain so i can extend all of these
results to this case as well yes I
wasn't but yeah does that answer your
question so how's the question but I
yes and then the question is whether
iterating so these techniques don't
appear right now to extend to sort of
iterating this multiple times because
you can introduce all sorts of weird
dependencies when you do that and the
mutual information bounds and and things
start to break down yeah that's a great
question so we can we can deal with some
kind of like sequential version of
interactivity but not not like it's not
like z3 can then you can go is back and
ask for more from z1 this no yeah good
question all right well have a breakdown
thank John again